s'est passé cet été la personne âgée il
vivait ici c'est plus elle est toujours
notre monde donc il centenaire la vie
rentrer chez elle deux jeunes et lui ont
cassé doigts pour les prendre à sa vague
il ya aussi eu un peu peur du tigre et
je n'ai rien ici si vous poussez la
porte tout simplement
et pourtant il ya un digicode tout neuf
il sert à rien n'importe qui peut
rentrer dans cet immeuble et commettre
un délit
c'est ouvert à tout le monde sait ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières semaines là un
des immeubles qui avait été visité le 28
décembre
on est intervenu avec le collectif
la police arrive là bas qu ils ont pu
s'échapper à travers le des échafaudages
qui donne côté cour et qui sont sortis
secours du rhône et quinze jours après
appel ils sont revenus au même square
c'est là où je les ai interpellé avec la
police sans usage de la force
juste du flag aux deux squares de la
dordogne et donc quand on les a
interpellés il avait les outils pour
cambrioler et leur cahier de
correspondance à 24 heures de garde à
vue et la procureur décide de les
relâcher nous ont pourri la vie et on a
on arrive à les relâcher malgré leur
casier judiciaire qui est plein pied
plein
on comprend pas je pense qu'il faut
revoir ses lois sur la chaîne 2 sur les
jeunes délinquants mineurs c'est pas
possible ça peut plus continuer ils le
savent ça c'est jay si jamais je vois
des potentiels délinquants donc tout de
suite je fais sur l'application à watsa
et je signale la présence des ces
individus et 6 6 passes à la fuite à ce
moment-là mois déjà les voisins sont
prêts
vous voyez là on arrive dans le quartier
des hauts de malesherbes où il avait
cette fameuse mixité sociale
apprenez par la ville de paris je suis
pas contre bien au contraire mais un
mauvais choix je pensais dans le on
appris dans l'attribution des
appartements parce que vous avez un
mélange privés et publics et biens qui
sont privées qui payent 13 14 mille
euros du mètre carré est il si on se
retrouvait avec une population qui
s'attendait pas à voir et le cadre c
leucate s'est bien dégradée et
d'ailleurs les jeunes délinquants
mineurs dont je vous parlais sont issus
de ces quartiers
on n'est pas et milices si on le
rappeler on est tout simplement un
collectif de citoyens vigilants et
bienveillant et on veut protéger nos
familles mais en respectant les lois
républicaines bien évidemment loi
m'interdit pas de de réagir bien
évidemment ça sera proportionnée et j'ai
ensuite j'appelle la police et et qui
après feront le boulot
on attend de paris habitat comment vous
dire de mettre un vrai dispositif de
portes sécurité concernant les portes
d'entrée des immeubles et on devrait
sécuriser nos rues et nos bâtiments
parle par le biais de caméras vidéo
surveillance qui franchement pour le
coup je les vis dans certains quartiers
ou dans certains immeubles c'est
dissuasif
non